AHMET ALP BALKAN: So we
just finished our talk
about Kubectl Plugins.
As Google, we have developed
this Kubectl Plugin Manager,
which is called Krew.
In our talk, we
explained what are
some challenges in
the Kubectl Plugin
ecosystem, why should
you use plugins,
and how would you
[INAUDIBLE] the plugin,
how would you distribute it
and bring it to more users.
So in our talk, we've gone
through some best practices.
We explained how to
make plugins palatable
and what sort of problems
do plugins solve.
So last time we talked,
Krew Plugin Manager
actually had something like 15
to 20 plugins that it hosted.
But this year, we actually
have over 60 plugins.
So the Kubectl Plugin
ecosystem is actually
growing pretty fast.
So if you're a developer who's
interested in Kubectl Plugin
development, which is writing
your subcommands for Kubectl,
please check out the talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]